[Music]
camera is rolling
now i'll show you how to cook healthy
food not just for you but for the
climate
[Music]
almost a third of food produced
worldwide goes to waste
food waste is a global issue that has a
negative impact on waste management
systems food insecurity biodiversity and
pollution
88 million tons of food waste is
generated in the eu each year costs
associated with this are estimated at
143 billion euros the european
commission is committed to halving food
waste per capita at the retail and
consumer level by 2030.
as food waste affects many different
areas there are also many ways to fight
it hannah and theresa work for restless
bluegreek a german non-profit
organization campaigning for a more
sustainable food consumption they
regularly rescue surplus food for
educational projects
at their headquarters in berlin they
teach people how to cook good and
healthy meals using the food they
recover
showing how to make these
underappreciated ingredients into tasty
dishes is also a way to reduce wastage
across germany 18 million tons of food
are thrown away every year that is
totally absurd
we campaign for this food to be reused
for it to be returned to the food cycle
and for people to understand what it's
all about what effects it has on the
climate when we throw away so much food
every day
today hannah is doing a live cooking
masterclass for the association's
followers this online event is also part
of the
planetary health challenge
an international initiative looking to
raise awareness about the best diet for
people and planet
[Music]
let's take a look at how a business is
making a profit out of reducing food
waste
surplus supermarkets and berlin sell
foods that can be visually unappealing
mislabeled or close to expiring all
their products are inspected to ensure
they are safe to eat before being sold
in 2020 alone we were able to save 3.5
million products at surplus so of course
we are helping to ensure that these
products are not thrown away and we are
also doing our bit for sustainability
and fighting greenhouse gas emissions
getting people involved in saving food
is at the heart of the foodsharing.de
initiative
it's an online platform that coordinates
the pickup of excess food that is still
edible from people retailers and
producers and takes it for free to
public distribution centers
it's a completely open movement anyone
can join in and get involved that's very
important to us we are in a
participatory movement we have over 10
000 active participants in berlin
one such member is lena she explains
what prompted her to become a volunteer
and a user of this food sharing network
it's been tired from food sharing i am
part of food sharing because i think
that far too much edible food is thrown
away and i want to do something about
that
that's why i rescue food and use the
distributors i also want to show him how
sustainable food handling works
now back to hannah and her tasty looking
dish
saving the planet can taste so delicious
we have now cooked all of this from
salvage food and it looks totally great
and it tastes really great
[Music]